foreign
hi Danielle how are you
hey I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um I have a question my husband and I
have been married for nine years and
we've handled our finances pretty
terribly and we've kind of been having a
moment of Reckoning
um we've been looking into trying to
start budgeting but we've kind of gotten
ourselves in such a bond that
to start bedding we're not really sure
how to there's not a lot left out of
each check to be able to put back
so I got a log Jam how do we start yeah
yeah what's your household income
um it depends he works a lot of overtime
he makes 28 10 an hour so give or take
he brings home about 1100 ish a week
so he's making fifty sixty thousand
dollars a year take-home pay so I'm
making 80 grand and you are at home with
the kiddos
yes sir I have three little girls okay
what age
they are eight
um my middle one will be six in about
three weeks and I have a one-year-old
and how much debt do you have not
counting your house
um I'm not counting our house it's
around 26
000 give or take
I don't know what vehicles uh a lot of
credit cards that and our vehicle
and one or two loans what are y'all in
the car
about 9 200-ish
other cars paid for
no sir we owe about nine I said the
other car is paid for
oh yes sir my husband's little truck is
paper okay good
and he said that he's got he's been
working quite a bit of overtime how many
hours has he been doing a week
um he's putting in around
60 plus hours a week
okay it's about 20 over so does he seem
pretty maxed out in his ability to work
any extra yeah yeah he's exhausted I
mean he's he's still plugging along but
I don't know how the hell I want to know
how to help him and you know I can't go
work outside of the home with three kids
by the time you know I don't really have
any skills we're we're Christians we
believe in the Life staying home with
the children and so I don't really have
any skills as far as you know the
workforce so but even if I did find a
job all it would go to daycare so it
would be awesome rent or own your home
right now
we're paying a mortgage right now okay
how much is that a month
975
all right there's nothing in this math
that you gave us that screams stupid
okay okay but what you are you're dying
Death By A Thousand Cuts it's a lot of
little stuff
right and sometimes when I talk to
someone in your situation you know they
got a 32 000 car
okay and if you had a 32 000 car that
that would scream stupid okay and I'd be
going to sell your stupid car okay you
have a nine thousand dollar car that's
not that's not crazy it's it's we've got
to get rid of the debt you can't breathe
and life's not good I'm not discounting
that situation but I don't see a single
item that if I pull that lever it
changes things quickly you don't have a
single item because you got a lot of
little ones does that make sense right
yes sir so what that ends up telling me
is a couple of things one is the two of
you uh resetting your minds and
committing to we are going to manage
money instead of it managing us
yes there's kind of a roar like
going out to eat
we are not going on vacation
we are selling so much stuff the kids
think they're next and we're going to do
the written budget and we're going to
stick to it
and we're not gonna buy crap on the
Internet or crap at Costco or crap in
the mall and you kind of got to get mad
you hear what I'm saying
yeah my husband's kind of reached that
place he is so tired of working so hard
but you got to reach it you got to reach
it because you're the full-time home
economist
yeah right yeah which means pinching
these pennies Consignment sale clothes
our kids at the Ramsey house grew up and
experienced clothing okay
all right so I mean and then they went
to college debt free okay and and and
now they're grown-ups and none of them
are in counseling due to the clothing
that they didn't get
so that's right you know so I mean the
stuff that we all do in America and and
Danielle you are not doing anything
dramatically stupid but you're doing a
lot of little tiny stupid things that
are killing y'all
right that's exactly right and that's
that that's going to be where you can
give your husband a back rub
by saying I'm gonna make I'm gonna be
the coupon queen
I'm gonna cook from scratch and save
money
I'm not gonna whine about going out to
eat or going on vacation or whatever
and we're going to start punching this
stuff in the face and I'm emotionally
going to carry 60 of this
uh this Crusade that your family is
getting ready to go on to get your life
back
right because your credit card debt was
just when you got disorganized sloppy
and lazy
yes it was the worst that we ever did
was to get a credit card yep but I mean
it's just you did not do a single thing
with credit cards that was silly you did
lots of little things
right and by the way that makes you kind
of normal but normal sucks we don't be
normal anymore it's not fun right all
right so then then he's going to be more
energized because he's going to start
seeing
traction from his hard work and he can
work he can work 70 instead of 60. for a
short period of time because right now
he thinks he's going to do this his
whole life and I'm saying he's gonna
have to do this for two years
I can do anything for two years but I
can't do it for 20.
right and and so right now he feels like
a rat and a wheel because you're he's
working all the time and getting nowhere
right but if we're get if we're working
all the time and we're making traction
and we got rid of that credit card then
we got rid of that credit card then we
got rid of that credit card and now we
got the car off and God think about what
it'd be like to have no payments but a
house payment around your place
it'd be wonderful yeah I mean Lord Jesus
this would be fun
this would be good well and Danielle if
you if you want to work if you want to
contribute financially I wouldn't write
off your ability you know to figure that
out there's a lot of moms who watch an
extra kid or two in order to get a
little extra income so I mean dog walk
for the neighbor I mean and involve the
kids in it you can do all kinds of crap
that's that's 20 and 30 bucks an hour uh
and do 10 of those things a week you
know and never be away from your kids
you know you can do all that while
they're at school so you're you're
perfect we think people like you are
awesome because you are ready that's why
I'm excited for you that's where all
this volume is coming from so you hold
on we're going to put you through
Financial Peace University you and your
husband it's a nine lesson class you
hang on we're gonna pay for it because
and I want you to call me back and when
you're scared and when you're beat up
and when you don't know what to do we're
gonna cheer you on and then when you
finally make it we're gonna do a debt
free stream today